I got a lot of problems coming up in my opinion with the famous
island. >> That island was uh really a cesspool. There's
no question about it. Just ask Prince Andrew. >> Hugely
Trump favored place. Everybody is saying no. This is unacceptable.
You have to release the files. Later in the post, Trump also
says that these are radical left inspired documents. And to so
consistently Trump has hinted that maybe these guys were involved
with Epstein. Maybe it was bad. >> After Elon Musk, who
worked with Trump for many months, said that Donald Trump is
in the Epstein.
>> What are we doing? What? What do you
>> Okay. All right. I I still got to delay. Okay. I don't
delayed.
>> I'm just so excited for like And it's I'm probably building
it up too much. Trust me, I'm probably building it up too much,
but the Will Stansel stuff is so funny to me that I don't want
to do it yet. I need uh I need more people to pile in. Okay.
Well, check out the Coffeezilla video on Epstein. He wants to
bury the Epstein files.
>> Is trying to cover the >> Trump's having such
a bad day the past two days. Just the worst day. >> The
Epstein story. It's the double down right here on Truth Social.
A big post saying that actually it's the Democrats who wrote
the Epstein files. This is just after Elon Musk, who worked with
Trump for many months, said that Donald Trump is in the Epstein.
That's the real reason they have not been made public. Obviously,
we've already seen deflections from the president about Epstein,
saying that it's a disgrace to talk about him. >> Are you
still talking about Jeffrey Epstein? It just seems uh like a
>> But today, it goes a step further. Quick context. There's
been a lot of infighting in the Republican party over basically
who's at fault for the giant botch of the Epstein files with
the >> I just want to know why people are saying there's
tens of thousands of videos like child videos and there's like
nobody to prosecute.
Did EP was Epstein just get diddling all these kids? I got the
impression Epste was not diddling all the kids but maybe maybe
that's what they're going to say. >> The majority of Republicans
not wanting to believe that Trump >> Did anyone step down
yet? I believe Dan Bonino
Dan Bangino Dan Bangino
stepped down himself was against a full release but rather that
he was sort of tricked into not releasing the Epstein files by
one of his lackeyis. But today Donald Trump came out and basically
backed Pam Bondi saying they're all going after Pam Bondi who's
doing a fantastic job all over a guy who never dies. Jeffrey
Epstein for years it's Epstein over and >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I don't need I don't need the read on
this again. a hugely Trump favored place. >> Sorry, we
saw it where he basically I'll just I'll actually go back and
just give my analysis really quickly. They created the Epstein
files just like they created the fake Hillary Clinton Christopher
Steel dossier. Like he's basically saying these Epstein files
that we have are a hoax. That's what he's saying. Which to me
means he's in them in some way that's incredibly uncomfortable
to him, right? Like clearly it's there's no reason to come out
like this unless you're basically admitting you're in >> the
Hillary Clinton steel dossier. There ain't issue. Epste never
has been. It's the people versus the predators, not left verse
right. The people versus the pedals. The people versus the people
on planes. There ain't no left verse right here. In fact, some
of the people who want this the most are people on the right.
Even on Truth Social, obviously. Oh, Bangino has not has not
resigned yet. He's just considering it. I see >> a hugely
Trump favored place. Everybody is saying no, this is unacceptable.
You have to release the files. Later in the post, Trump also
says that these are radical left inspired documents and to not
waste time and energy on Jeffrey Epstein, somebody that nobody
cares about. But actually, we all do care about it. You know
who doesn't actually want this out? I feel like the funny thing
is is probably if you pulled for like a a joint issue for people
who were kind of center center or even potentially slightly leftleaning
who would have voted for Trump. I feel like this would be one
of the absolute top issues is like I actually am a little bit
concerned about like corruption and covering this up. This would
be like every one of Trump's swing voters this was a major thing,
right? also all of his base voters, but I'd say a lot of like
older Republicans would have just voted on the rep on the economy
or something, right? They would have said, "Oh, Joe Biden sucks.
He's a he's a communist. We'll vote for for Trump." But basically,
everybody who's tapped in online, young people, his core his
core like fan base, dude, these people all wanted this more than
anything. And his responses are crazy. >> The elites, that's
why they've never done it. That's why it was a compelling pitch
when Donald Trump hinted to his base that maybe he was going
to release the files. People largely didn't trust the job that
Biden had done. That's why it was a compelling story. So the
idea now that it was Biden and Obama who invented the Epstein
files is absolutely preposterous. They don't want that out either.
And maybe that's because as a producer of 60 Minutes alleged,
Justain Maxwell implied that there were tapes on Trump and also
tapes on Clinton. You know who else said it? Mark Epstein. Jeffrey
Epstein's brother saying Epstein said what I know about both
candidates the 2016 election would have to be cancelled. So this
whole idea that this is a left or right thing it's not. It's
the elites. Anybody who was on that plane, anybody who was associated
with Epstein, seen with Epstein, even if they did nothing wrong,
they don't want that out. Everyone who wasn't seen with Epstein,
wasn't on that plane, of course they all want the files out.
And what's interesting is obviously the Trump administration
has sort of played footsie with this idea for a long time playing
to their base. They know >> Wait, what?
At least the files Donald Trump child. Jesus the Elmo account
on Twitter's dude. Wait, this there's no way this is an Elmo
account actually ran by like Sesame Street. Is it? Bro, this
this appears to be the official Elmo account. There's no way
that was that re Oh, what that would be I wonder if this is Oh,
hold on.
Please. The account is also posting virolently anti-Semitic and
genocidal content which we will not share. Oh no, Elmo. No, somebody
Grock Grock has has actually taken over. Okay. Grock has assumed
direct control of the Elmo account. Mecca is back. Okay. And
he just wants you to tickle him. Okay, dude.
Oh, this is a big issue. They had the influencers stand out there
with a bunch of released material. But we also showed clips of
Donald Trump implying that maybe Bill Clinton and Prince Andrew
were doing bad. >> Oh, hold on. Archive tweet of >> things
on the island. >> Bill Clinton got a lot of problems coming
up in my opinion with the famous >> That island was uh
really a cesspool. There's no question about it. Just ask Prince
Andrew. >> So consistently Trump has hinted that maybe
these guys were involved with Epstein. Maybe it was bad. >> Oh
god.
Yeah, Elmo was uh Elmo was going off. Okay, Elmo was doing some
crazy. Elmo was saying some crazy not good. Elmo, stop. Elmo,
no.
But turns out all these guys knew each other and knew Epstein.
We know this in part from a Piers Morgan interview where he talked
to a lady who went to a dinner. >> Guys, guys, Elmo here.
I'm I'm going to send this over to the count. He's going to teach
us about the Holocaust >> party with Trump, Clinton, Epstein,
and Prince Andrew. >> Extraordinary collection of very
high power people. How did they all interact with Epstein? How
did Trump, Clinton, Prince Andrew interact with him? >> They
everyone was very very pie with him, you know. Um, it was like
there was close bonds. You could see that. >> So these
guys knew each other, apparently had dinner parties together,
all of them together. Trump later accuses two of the guys of
doing bad things and then when we release the files, can we release
the files? That's uh that's crazy to be the the guy who's you
went to
island, you the kids and then you came back and figured two other
metaphorically finger two other people as from that island. That
takes balls, okay, to be like, dude, these guys I bet these guys
kids when when you were like there triple penetrating some child
with them, okay? absolutely disgusting behavior. But also,
how how how
do you think he'd get away with it? He became president twice
after that. >> Well, no, actually, no. We can't do that.
Nobody cares about that. The reason why seems obvious. Epste
knew Prince Andrew. Yes. He knew Bill Clinton. Yes. But he also
knew Donald Trump. And recently, tapes were released of Epstein
talking and calling Donald Trump his closest friend. >> So,
how do you know this?
I suppose it's right. >> So, it makes intuitive sense to
distance yourself from files that may or may not have your name
in it and even distance yourself from the people involved. It's
worth stating Trump actually denied knowing Prince Andrew. >> I
don't know Prince Andrew. >> Of course, this was immediately
debunked by photos showing the two together and of course showing
that they clearly knew each other as of 2000. Now, the reason
you would deny knowing Prince Andrew even though you did is obvious.
at the time he was facing allegations related to Epstein. By
the way, allegations that now are basically over. Prince Andrew
is very happy about us dropping the Epstein probe. A source for
the Sun said. >> Give me two seconds. I'll be right back.
We're going to keep watching this. I'm going to back it up a
little bit so I don't miss too much. Be back. >> Calling
Donald Trump his closest friend. >> So, how do you know
closest friend? So, it makes intuitive sense to distance yourself
from files that may or may not have your name in it and even
distance yourself from the people involved. It's worth stating
Trump actually denied knowing Prince Andrew. >> I don't
know Prince Andrew. >> Of course, this was immediately
debunked by photos showing the two together and of course showing
that they clearly knew each other as of 2000. Now, the reason
you would deny knowing Prince Andrew, even though you did, is
obvious. At the time, he was facing allegations related to Epstein.
By the way, allegations that now are basically over. Prince Andrew
is very happy about us dropping the Epstein probe. A source for
the Sun said he's only been abroad once since the scandal erupted.
Prince Andrew has always been very nervous about going abroad
and always looking over his shoulder, as he should be in my opinion.
But now he's very happy because the guy who never met him but
was photographed with him in 2000 uh just ended the investigation.
Now, I have to say Trump's been pretty >> meeting him at
a party isn't the same as knowing him, though. I mean, I would
say so. I'll like even shaking his hand and being like friendly.
I don't know if that's the same thing. Like why a business guy
would want to shake hands with like a royal although when he
shook his hand in that photo, I think Prince Andrew was under
investigation. So, who knows?
But yeah, I think a lot of these people get photographed together
at parties or something. I don't know what it necessarily means.
I don't know if it means they're close. Trump. Either way, Trump
and Epstein were close and that's like undeniable. Not just because
of the tape saying they were close, but obviously Donald Trump
talked about having like knowing a lot about Jeffrey, >> consistent
on the fact he has no interest in releasing the Epstein files
in full. He said this multiple times. The reason most people
have sort of a false memory of this, the reason it's sort of
a Mandela effect that he campaigned on the idea of releasing
the Epstein Files is because Fox News released a deceptively
edited clip where they cut out the part where he said, "Yeah,
I'll probably release the Epstein Files and they cut out the
part where then he backtracks on that." Dude, he immediately
backtracks on that is the funniest thing. Like, dude, if that
if they if they didn't air that or sorry, if they didn't, I guess
do this thing where they put out a clip where it was edited out.
Dude, that's such a bad look. How How is that clip not played
to infinity in the leadup to the election? >> Would you
declassify the Epstein files?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I would. >> And that's the part most
of us saw. Of course, later people found out that the full clip
showed him saying basically the opposite. >> I guess I
would. I think that less so because you know you don't know it's
you don't want to affect people's lives if it's phony stuff in
there because there's a lot of phony stuff with that whole world.
We also have I guess like in a technical sense you could almost
argue he's being consist he is being consistently hesitant to
even talk about the Epstein pot just guys what are you asking
me about Jeffrey Epstein for who's that guy I don't even know
who that is. >> Bill O'Reilly on News Nation saying he
just talked to Trump back on St. Patrick's Day and Trump basically
said the same thing. >> He said, and I agree, there are
a lot of names associated with Epste. It had nothing to do with
Epstein's conduct. They they maybe had lunch with him or maybe
had some correspondence for one thing or another. If that name
gets out, those people are destroyed because there's not going
to be any context. Media doesn't care uh about context. So, you
you can't do that. So over and over we've seen the same answer
from the president. Not the fact that oh no the >> uh hello
hello
uh 51 Bard thanks for the raid. Thank >> files. It's a
lefty conspiracy. No actually it's the worry that people in the
files are going to have their lives destroyed by the files. That
sounds a lot more like covering for the people in the files than
it does covering the victims. We've heard Cash Patel and Pam
Bondi talk about, "Oh, we got to protect the victims." >> Go
through it very cautiously to protect all the victims. >> We're
not going to revictimize women. We're not going to put that back
out >> But when we actually hear the president talk about
it and the real reason, right, because he's ultimately the decision
maker on whether this gets released, what the real reason is
cited is not about victims. It is about the people the name >> it
is it is the the true victims the rich and influential people
who might have known this guy and not okay
you'd think you'd think okay you'd think somebody who was elected
as president would have the self-sacrifice required to say yeah
we got to find out who these kids and we got to put them in jail
but Trump's real priority is like guys there's some very nice
influential people who I know personally who might have their
names in those files okay and they'd be the real victims if we
put their name out there. All right. You can't just you can't
just put people's names out there as people who associated with
this guy. Come on, man. >> In the thing. So, I find it
disgusting they're using the victims of Epstein as a shield for
the people who are actually in these files. Now, of course, who
specifically is he worried about? Well, maybe it's his friends.
Maybe it's people he has dinner parties with. And of course,
maybe it's him, Donald Trump, that he's worried about. The journalist
Michael Wolf actually quotes Steve Bannon as saying Jeffrey Epstein
was really feared in 2016 for what he knew. >> I was there
and it was that that that moment and um Bannon said to Epstein
and he said this in a in >> I mean Biden's government at
least went after Diddy. Well, sure. Diddy is not on the same
tier as Jeffrey Epstein. Like the allegations for Jeffrey Epste
and the people who like he was associated with. Those are like
some of those powerful people in politics or like billionaires,
right? It's not quite the same. As much as those people have
a lot of power in entertainment who are around Diddy and like
there obviously were like it seems very obvious to me there are
serious crimes committed by Diddy, it's not the same level of
blackmail. It's not blackmailing for the same kind of favors,
right? It's still really bad. It still needs to be prosecuted,
needs to be like taken down, but the the Epstein stuff like the
allegations there still yet to be like substantially proven.
Uh the allegations are just cra like mind-blowing, right? Trump
was with
>> Uh was Trump with Diddy that much? I don't know if Trump
was with Diddy that >> In a good humor, he said during
the campaign, that would be the 2016 campaign, you meaning Jeffrey
Epstein, were the only person I was afraid of. So, that is three
independent sources. You've got the Ira Rosen quote, the Michael
Wolf quote, and there's no way he made that exact Bro, really?
There's no way he made that exact point, is there? That's kind
of nuts that Trump might have been projecting onto Bill Clinton
or onto Hillary Clinton.
There's a lot of bad stuff coming out, you know, Bill and that
whole island. He's like sitting there himself like, I really
hope that island doesn't get talked about. that Mark Epstein
quote all saying that there is some type of damaging information
on Trump. Two of those people specifically implying that it's
also on Clinton as well. You also have the Elon Musk allegation
from left field, but he doesn't source anybody, so we won't count
that. Either way, I must say I don't know for sure if Bill Clinton,
Prince Andrew, Donald Trump were heavily involved in anything
nefarious or not. That is exactly Oh, say I thought Coffeezilla
would say it. Okay, Donald Trump is clearly a Coffeezilla say
it. He's clearly a
hash should trend everywhere. >> Why we should all demand
that we open these files? But the possibility of both Democrats
and Republicans being implicated in some of these files, whether
they did it or not or just knew him, may give a plausible reason
for why the Epstein files have been heavily redacted this whole
time. There are very powerful people involved. We've known that.
The reason we've been given, of course, is that, you know, we've
got to protect the victims. The real reason behind the scenes
is really they're protecting the powerful people. Now, the most
charitable interpretation is, as Bill O'Reilly said, it's because
those people would have their lives ruined. They had nothing
to do with Epstein. But we know some of them probably did. We
know this from the Miami Herald because the FBI agents who searched
Epstein's house found a cache of thick black binders all labeled
with names that contained hundreds of naked or semi- naked photographs
on CDs that Epstein stored in various places. The labels on the
binders were redacted from photos because prosecutors said they
were names of third parties who were not relevant to the case
they are mounting against Justlain Maxwell. So my question,
Dude, hold on.
What are those? >> Bro, there's no way. Okay, there's no
way. Dude, can I get the wire? Can I hold on? I need the I need
the wire clip. Okay, >> for a cold ass crew of gangsters,
y'all carried it like Republicans and y'all remember, man, talk
this up when you hit them bricks.
Oh, for a >> cold ass crew of gangsters. Y'all carried
it like Republicans and
>> yo remember man, talk this up when you hit them bricks.
Best way to get more
>> benefits of this thing. >> I just think about
this drama >> when I see those binders. >> Anybody
got problems with anybody else here, we bring it to the group.
We ain't got to take it to the streets. All right, let's do it.
>> Yo, what is that? >> Robert say we got to have
minutes for a meeting, right? He's the menace.
>> Is you taking notes on a criminal conspiracy? What the
[__] is you thinking, man? >> Like, why are
you taking actual detailed Why is this Why does this exist? Why
would you keep this like on your shelf? What the is going on
here? What is going on? Why would this just be in like thumb
drives? This should be This should be purely like digitally handled.
There's no way you should or if if there's stuff like this, this
should be in like a lock box at some bank, right? If this is
real, if these were names of like powerful people, these need
to be in a lock box at a bank. Imagine if Epstein stored them
in like a Google Drive with a public link. Yeah, it' be pretty
binders full of CDs. I understand they're binders full of CDs,
but clearly if they were binders full of encrypted CDs, they
wouldn't have gone here, opened them up, and known they were
binders full of naked women. Oh my god, is Mitt Romney involved?
photos because prosecutors said they were names of third parties
who were >> lock box. Well, what do you call what do you
call it in a bank, right? The not a lock box, like a safety deposit
box. Yeah, a safety deposit box. That's what I mean. >> Not
relevant to the case they are mounting against Just Lane Maxwell.
So, my question is, are those some of the third parties? Their
names are on binders with a bunch of explicit photographs that
Epstein was storing. That seems like something we should be
>> that. Dude, could you imagine if that was just like
actual politicians and [__] with their names on the
binders? Like if to me I'm like, dude, there's just no way. But
isn't that the way it always is? Like you think people are competent
and it's actually like even the people in the highest levels
of power are just the most incompetent people. I don't know.
Or what about the fact that since the FBI is saying there's no
blackmail involved with Jeffrey Epstein, we investigate the Wall
Street Journal report that Jeffrey Epstein allegedly tried to
extort Bill Gates over an extrammarital affair because I thought
there was no blackmail involved. And my real plea to people is
to not allow comments like this, these statements about
partisan politics to trick you into thinking this is some type
of left verse right issue. That is the Trump. Dude, have we got
a status update on Rob No? Can I go check Rob No's Twitter right
now? Is Rob No doing okay? How's Rob No doing right now?
Rob, how you feeling? I really respect Scott Adams, but massively
disagree with him here. Perhaps my stream tonight. I'll go through
his reasoning here step by step and explain why. Oh, hold on.
Hold on. >> I said, >> wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Trump telling us to move
on from Epste is a commander-in-chief decision. I know there's
a lot of disagreement on this topic, but I watch how I persu
but watch how I persuade 98% of you who disagree with me over
to my side. Are you ready?
oh man,
I kind of want to watch this. By the way, it sounds like he's
he's like saying um he trusts Trump on this, which is crazy.
Uh, then again, the beeper MSAD pulled off clearly wasn't at
the wheel. Yeah, but that's the bro. Those guys are competent.
Ain't nobody ever there's not a single conspiracy about people
that alleges that they're incompetent. Okay? I'm gonna tell you
the only conspirac the only thing every single person who hates
people agrees on that these people are extremely competent, extremely
calculated.
Okay? And the people who by the way the people who like also
think that. Okay? There's not a single find me the person who's
like no Jewish pe people broadly very incompetent. Yeah. I I
don't trust them at all. I go to a lawyer. I'm like no get me
a white guy. Get me, get me an Asian lawyer right now. No way.
I need an Asian lawyer. I'm just saying. I'm just saying. Okay.
Dancing Israelis were kind of incompetent if they were actually
MSAD. Would that even be incompetence? Why would you assume anybody
would know what you were dancing about? Why would that even be
incompetence? Why would anybody look at those people? It's like
insane happen stance that those people were seen at all like
that they were seen and like uh like reported on. In all seriousness,
I think intelligence agencies probably have wings that are extremely
competent. Oh, yeah. Sure. The American intelligence agencies.
Sure. Bro, what what power Trump has to make people not want
to know about? Yeah. No, he has no power to do that. I I kind
of want to watch this Scott Adams thing now. Dilbert guy. Dilbert
guy is going the wrong direction. Tucker Carlson says Dan Bonino
got completely shafted in the Epste mess. Kind of wrecks Dan's
career. It's pretty hard for Dan to go back to his podcast audience
and be like, I'm telling you the truth when they all think he's
covering up for Epstein. Okay, Rob seems pretty upset. Rob's
pretty upset. Lindsey Graham says in the coming days, Trump will
unleash weapons to Ukraine at a record level along with reenacting
unprecedented unprecedented sanctions against Russia. Bro, okay,
where's the Oh, boy. That's like good, I guess, but also is Trump
getting blackmailed by somebody? This seems really out of character.
What's going on with this guy?
>> What's What's going on with this guy?
The DOJ releasing all the names associated with Jeffrey Epstein
would screw over global markets. Would you still want it to happen?
Yes. >> Potentially criminal. Okay. All right.
>> Okay. Here's here's the big tweet. Potentially there
are three outcomes I can see from the Trump Epste debacle. Oh,
maybe not. One one year ago, President Trump was almost murdered
at a rally. Release the Epstein files.
>> What? I This is a cryptic tweet. What the? One year
ago, President Trump was almost murdered at a rally. Release
the Epstein files. How am I supposed to read this tweet? What
is this supposed to
>> There's definitely a read of this tweet that's not insane.
That is like
it was bad a year ago.
Release the files now. I don't think Rob would tweet that. But
there's a read of this that I'm like, Rob, I don't Rob, what
are you doing, buddy? You're not supposed to do this. Getting
on some lists. Cool. Say goodbye to midterms. Yeah, Rob's uh
Rob is not happy. All right, we'll finish copies >> play
right now. I don't think it's going to work. I think it's a disaster.
I think it's very stupid. I think people on the right are stupid
as people on the left. I think this is a universal issue, as
it should be. If there are predators in the highest offices in
the land, be they Democrat or Republican. Who is the guy who's
talking about phase two on the files? Maybe it would have been
Cash or
In any case, like the the phase two thing was supposed to happen.
They had a phase one that they announced as a phase one. It was
like the whole the whole government was aligned on that. >> We
want to know about it.
>> That's true. We do want to know about it. [__]
Coffeezilla getting massive views off of the Epstein stuff. By
the
>> dude, I It's so funny that they they spent all this
time getting people in the most conspiratorial mindsets and now
it's like working backwards against them perfectly. Like they're
totally getting by it.
It almost, you know, it almost makes you not almost makes you
believe in God kind of thing, you know. >> Reads as a threat.
Oh, by the way, this Yeah, it reads as a threat to me. It's kind
of crazy that Rob was tweeting that good logic say. You built
a base rooted in values and transparency. That's one way of saying
it. Can I come out and say, "Trust me, bro. We lied to you for
six years, but the need to protect children on this whole and
this whole issue. Move on. There's no way to bungle this harder."
It really That is a good tweet, right? That is a very good tweet.
I think uh other than the absolute cope about values and transparency,
that's like complete cope. You you actually can't build a base
around conspiratorial thinking and telling people that you have
to vote for us because they're [__] kids. You have
to vote for us because they're kids. You have to vote for us
because they're [__] kids. And you get there and
they're like, "Well, really destroy the kid lives if we released
all the names." So, well, that's not technically what they're
saying. That's very bad faith. Hold on. It could ru ruin the
lives of people who aren't kid if we release these names. And
so we will protect both those people and the kid,
>> Like that is clearly the maybe the only way you absolutely
obliterate this this movement completely that there would be
no movement. And what what incredible cosmic justice that would
be. No, if they if they actually destroyed this movement that
Peter Teal and Co just invested billions of dollars getting on
the good side of getting into office, getting the vice president
who they have under under their thumb, and then that entire movement
is obliterated and it's back to neocons.
Wouldn't that be Wouldn't that be hilarious? That'd be really
funny. Innocent until proven guilty, guys. Release the list and
trust the people to believe in the principles of innocent until
proven guilty. Oh boy.
F I think that's just you. Be very vivic. Although I will probably
since we're coming up on what, an hour and a half on the stream,
I'm probably gonna end the Twitch stream. Go kick only at some
point here. Just so you know,
just so you know, the neocons are still there, too. War started.
Yeah, I realize you have a totally way of looking at this. It's
not the neocons. It's not the same group. It's people who like
who are good with going to wars. It's like weak people who could
be manipulated. I know you, but you're you're totally wrong.
I'm just not going to argue it with you. Only people mute. I
understand you think that they're the same as the neocons. They're
not. populists are not the same as the neocons. They're totally
different. All of the neocon politicians been run out of office.
They're all resigning. They're all failing. They're all getting
primar. But you'll look at all of this and go, "Well, they're
just it's different neocons or something." And then totally,
I guess, sidestep the fact that that's the reason the distinction
is there. Anyway,
anyway, anyway, I can finally go to the Will Stansel stuff. What
I'm going to do is I'm going to send everybody to kick because
there will be some rword content in this, okay?
and I don't know exactly what can go everywhere. So, I'm gonna
I'm gonna actually stop the Twitch stream, send everybody over
to Kick. We're going to go over to Kick and I will see you guys
there shortly. Okay,
I'll pin that in the chat. We'll see you guys there in just a
minute. All right, guys. Ending on Twitch. Going kick
multistreaming.
Boom. We're good. No